[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue à paris saclay autonomous
laddh notre expérimentation de services
de mobilité autonome à la demande
électrique et partager
cette expérimentation fait partie du
programme national sam evra sam evra
pour sécurité et acceptabilité de la
conduite autonome et de la mobilité
autonome
l'objectif est de faire bénéficier notre
expérimentation à plus de 250
utilisateurs que nous avons recruté pour
faire partie d'un panel afin de
comprendre et d'apprendre d'eux
d'apprendre de leur retour d'expérience
et puis de comprendre aussi à quel point
notre proposition est adapté aux besoins
du territoire et aux besoins en termes
de mobilité notamment
d'un utilisateur vous montez à bord de
nos eaux et cab qui font sur des bases
de zoé de série agrémenté de capteurs
qui permettent à la voiture d'être
autonome à l'intérieur nous avons un
ingénieur d'essais qui vérifie la
qualité du système est un opérateur de
sécurité derrière le volant apte à
prendre en main en cas de situation non
gérer car même si nos prototypes sont
autonomes la sécurité passe avant tout
j'ai postulé sur sur le site on va
envoyer une réponse comme quoi gt gt
prix entre guillemets ça m'a intéressé
je me suis dit que ça pouvait me
permettre de faire les trajets du rer
jusqu'à l'école et ça pouvait être
tragique ce serait plus rapide
c'est assez impressionnant de voir une
voiture se déplacer seules sont sans
l'assistance dans l'humain
je suis en école d'ingénieur je fais un
cursus data science donc je fais
beaucoup de d'intelligence artificielle
donc c'est un peu un peu mon domaine
c'est un projet sur lequel je pourrais
être amené par exemple à travailler et
donc il y avait ça aussi qui a fait que
ça ça m'a intéressé je voulais voir un
petit peu comment ça se passe et voir de
l'intérieur comment une voiture autonome
marché quoi c'est une expérience
intéressante à vivre
[Musique]